when you think about how to evaluate
where bitcoin is today are we winning
yet is uh global adoption here or do we
still have work to do like just walk me
through kind of the current framework
you look at as to where is bitcoin today
yeah so we you know
while we definitely have a lot of work
left to do and i think bitcoin has a lot
of room to grow
um
it's very hard if you've been around
since 2013 and definitely people who
have been around much earlier than that
like you know like 2011 2010
it's very hard to look at bitcoin now
and not feel like we already won you
know like the
the just this last year the amazing
things that happened like you know like
el salvador like we actually have an
actual government an actual country
that's embracing bitcoin fully that's
that was unimaginable you know like that
was
that was one of those things that we
were dreaming about and everyone was
telling us we were crazy so you see that
happening you cannot not feel like we've
won already you know
um that said there's definitely a lot of
room to grow i think that i think that
bitcoin is the best money there is at
the very least
uh it should be as big as gold at least
and i think it can get much bigger so
there's definitely there's definitely
room to grow for sure okay and then when
you look at the things that still need
to be worked on when you say hey here's
like the big bodies of work that bitcoin
still has ahead of it what are the
things that immediately pop to mind
right so
you know like on the technical side of
things it feels like and i'm like a
technical guy so it feels like um
one of the things i'm concerned about is
like privacy you know like
if you know on the surface level the
privacy with bitcoin seems like it's
strictly worse than what it is with like
say cash and i think if bitcoin becomes
uh
you know real way that everyone uses to
transact
that can become a problem we definitely
need to fix that
and you know things like lightning could
improve that
that's one thing i think we
i think we also maybe have
we
might have to like rethink how
how we position bitcoin
and how we
how we talk to
you
how we evangelize it really um which is
you know something i've done a lot of
people have done for many years now um
something you've done very successfully
um
i think you know institutions are
obviously
very interested but there's also the
non-institutional crowd
and i think a lot of them are asking
themselves like well why should i buy
bitcoin if i can buy doge in questions
like that which are i mean i think we
need to do a better job answering those
questions and and and uh that's
something i've been focusing a lot
lately on because i think bitcoin
be
something that you know every every
human on earth has
uh
a certain amount of their portfolio in
bitcoin i think this is where bitcoin
should be going and i think we can get
there but we need to we need to do a
good job of explaining why
what's up guys bang bang thanks so much
for watching the best business show
today if we're gonna be the best
business show we obviously need the best
partner that's why the exclusive sponsor
the best business show is sofi they're
an all-in-one platform that allows you
to invest in all kinds of different
assets including stocks etfs crypto ipos
and they even have an automated
investing function if that's your thing
so before we start getting after it
again make sure that you go download
sofi you get an invest account and when
you make your first crypto trade
regardless of what you buy they'll give
you 10 in bitcoin for free it's that
simple head on over to sofi.com to get
started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]
you